She said that she found out he almost
had a higher tolerance
baseline and they had the same increase
in production and sensitivity
and then they had lower,
it was lower.
What's critical is to find out how heart
rate
split,
which is also important.
It's not as important because there's a
response and some of the
more frequent,
more common
complex negative emotions like
resentment and guilt and hatred and
cruelty and the argument basically and
stuff.
You know,
when animals are afraid of the unknown,
but for human beings,
that fear is,
is increased by the fact that we also
abstractly understanding is since what
the unknown means.
Well,
the mere fact that we can abstract out,
I know she liked the unknown as such,
certainly isn't indicative of the fact
that our cognitive processes are
somewhat different than the,
from those of animals and I,
I tried to show using examples drawn
from both genesis and the story of the,
the fall of the Buddhists,
so to speak,
that mythology or some myths anyway,
present us with a story that says
that the development of self
consciousness is tantamount to the
contamination of existence with death.
I think the logic behind that basically
is that the defining feature of self
consciousness is knowledge of borders,
so to speak,
of our own personal borders and the most
tangible and horrifying of those borders
is our own knowledge of our mortality.
So in a sense,
it's the fact that we can see into the
future and know what that future means.
And so you could say in a sentence if
you want to get
mechanical about it,
that for human beings,
every aspect of existence serves as a
cue for punishment.
Now,
someone commented last week that if you
put an animal into an experimental
situation where it's subjected
constantly to unavoidable punishment,
that develops learned helplessness,
which is not alone,
that depression can also produce
aggression as a consequence of the
administration of such punishment.
So
we know already that the purpose of
group identification is to
provide stability in an ocean of
instability.
But what we've now added to this,
I think with this additional line of
argumentation is
more clear understanding of how,
just how terrible the ocean of
instability is for human beings in
particular.
Because,
yeah,
as I said before,
I'm,
I'm not just interested in figuring out
why animals defend their territory,
human beings and animals,
at least in terms of that idea.
I'm interested in why we go that final
extra date of distance,
which means that not only do we will we
kill to protect our territory,
but we'll engage in all sorts of
murderous torture along the way,
which seems gratuitous in a sense,
is that you like it's one thing to one,
eliminate your enemy and we understand
some of the motivations for doing it.
I mean,
someone who's foreign disrupts your
predictability.
Predictability is the essence of
security.
It's another thing to
Choo Choo.
Well,
as I said,
to make you,
I guess to make it an aesthetic of his
cruelty tend to pursue the opportunity
to inflict suffering on someone else
justified by your express patriotism
expressly,
but obviously motivated by something
that's more twisted and perverse.
So,
and that's the core question that this
course is trying to address this and
what is it that makes people like that?
No,
just patriotic but totalitarian,
patriotic,
and not just willing to defend borders,
but also
motivated to enjoy that construction of
cruelty for its own sake.
I want to read you a quote from
Solzhenitsyn to just start this off.
So this is his description of the
degradation of the state,
the real version as opposed to the
mythological version.
Soldier,
Solzhenitsyn quotes and Arthur who says,
I was told how executions were carried
out at a doc who was the camp on the
mature river.
They would take the opposition members
with their things out of the camp
compound on a prisoner transport at
night and outside the compound stood the
small house of the third section.
The condemned men were taken into a room
one at a time and were the camp guards
sprang on.
Their mouths were stuffed with something
soft and their arms were bound with the
courts behind their backs.
They were led out into the where
harnessed carts were waiting.
The bound prisoners were piled on the
cards from five to seven at a time and
driven off to the Gorkha,
which was the camp cemetery on arrival.
They were tipped into big pits that had
already been prepared and buried alive.
No one out of brutality.
No,
it had been ascertained rationally.
Then when dragging and lifting them,
it was much easier to cope with living
people.
Then with corpses,
the work land on for many nights at a
deck and social and it's and says that
is how the moral political unity of our
party was achieved.
Helipad,
he's described the degradation of the
state from the mythological perspective.
He says as well be known since the
compilation is made by our Andre h use
ner and Jg Fraser,
the delusion is almost universally
disseminated and is documented in all of
the continents of a rarely in Africa and
on various cultural levels.
A certain number of variants seemed to
be the result of dissemination,
first from Mesopotamia and then from
India.
It is equally possible that one or more
one or several actual dilulio
catastrophes gave rise to fabulous
narratives,
but it would be risky to explain.
So widespread myth by phenomena of which
know geologic and traces have been
found.
The majority of the flood myth Siemens
sends to form part of the cosmic rhythm.
The old world people by a fallen
humanity is submerged under the waters
and sometimes later a new world emerges
from the aquatic chaos.
While you're all familiar with that
general model,
you've seen that over,
over and over again and the diagrams
that I've
presented to,
it's just basically this notion
people have fallen humanity down by the
water who then reemerge.
That's the story of Noah for example,
but then he goes on to say,
this is very interesting.
It's really worth thinking about
because,
well,
I think it's worth thinking about.
I guess this past and struck me because
it echoed long after I thought up what
I'm going to tell you today what I had
in fact thought up,
which was that you can't say that a
state gets rotten and corrupt all on its
own,
although that happens merely as a
consequence of the passing of time,
which is to say that,
all right,
let's take the analogy of the
individual.
We all have childhood at one point,
and those personalities,
theoretically or healthy,
given our status as children,
but as time passed,
which basically meant as changed,
continued to happen,
we transformed from children and
adolescents.
And that meant that the childhood
personality considered as something
static would have turned pathological by
its own devices as we transformed into
adolescence because the attitude of a
child over were appropriate for a child
is not appropriate for an adolescent.
One of the things that added points out
says,
well,
that's an idea of the,
the,
the aging and senility of the cake.
Is that an idea that's good at one point
in your life may become pathological at
a later point.
So there's sort of,
it's just a consequence of entropy in a
sense.
Things always change and as a
consequence you have to run to keep up
with them.
But then really had,
he takes the argument a bit farther and
he says in a large number of variants,
the flood is a result of the sins or
ritual faults of human beings.
Sometimes it results simply from the
wish of a divine being to putting in to
mankind will know his story is very much
like that.
Anyways,
the chief causes seem to lie at once in
the sins of men and the decrepitude of
the world.
So Elliot,
he says,
well,
it's not just a matter of the fact that
things age and become decayed by
themselves,
but there's an additional twist on it,
which is that there's some contribution
according to the mythological mode,
thinking of the misbehavior of human
beings,
but makes the guard so upset they can't
stand the noise so to speak anymore.
They decided to do away with everything
that's being created.
So there's an,
there's a sin of commission as well as
an act of omission that leads to the
decrepitude of things.
In the end,
he says,
by the mere fact that it exists,
that is that it lives in,
produces the cosmos gradually
deteriorates and ends by falling into
decay.
This is why it has to be recreated,
recreated.
In other words,
the flood realizes on the macrocosmic
scale.
What is symbolic effected during the New
Year Festival?
The end of the world and the end of the
sinful humanity in order to make a new
creation possible.
Finally,
you might think about the myth that we
discussed a long time ago,
the Egyptian myth that underlies the The
Sun God status of the Pharaoh.
That's the myth of Ocirus horrocks.
Remember ocirus ends up being sent to
the underworld because of the treachery
of his brother Seth,
who the Egyptian myth states.
Clearly he didn't understand.
So the Egyptian myth states was that
first there was something fishy about
seth.
And second of all that he had such great
impact on our stairs because well
serious didn't understand what seth was
and that meant basically is trying to
point out,
so to speak to people that
if you don't understand what evil is,
that will defeat you.
And so what we're trying to do from at
least in this lecture and more or less
for the last three lectures,
is to come to some understanding of just
what evil consists of so that we can
decrease the likelihood that it will in
fact defeat us.
I was showing this manuscript to a
friend of mine on the weekend and he
found parts of the argument that I was
making.
I should,
I'm outline I gave you last week,
kind of unsettling in a sense because I
use a lot of terminology that's being
classically associated with the
religious thought I can,
can I,
you know this,
this disturbs me as well.
It's certainly,
at least it did.
As I was putting the manuscript
together,
because I had never was inclined.
I thought of my own accord to gravitate
towards religious language
and he asked me why I insisted upon
using words like evil when they have
this historical context that at least
places that partially into the domain of
religious thinking.
Well,
you know,
it would certainly make,
if I changed the terminology and
deemphasize the mythological language,
I could certainly make the sorts of
theories that I'm trying to present more
palatable.
But the fact is,
as far as I'm concerned,
that
the mere fact that we know anything at
all about evil is because of religious
constructions of precisely what evil is.
And it would be a mistake as a
consequence to abandon the historical
roots of the development of the idea,
just to make discussion of it more
palatable.
One thing that occurred to me when I was
reading is that you seem
to have changed their meanings somewhat
from the traditional religious sense and
goes,
where's your actually discuss concretely
in there?
But the good and good general,
they refer us to
a specific moral code and evil to
opposition to the Colu.
Yeah,
right,
and not as is when for instance needs to
finish his book beyond good and evil
refers to propose to them in that sense.
In other words that you're beyond that,
that split,
but then what Derryn Brian curb as good
and evil is sort of beyond the
traditional grid enable these.
That's right.
It's description of good and evil as
processes rather than as as things are
estates.
Yeah.
I was reading a little bit about the
French Revolution this morning because I
referred to it in this manuscript
somewhere or said that the French during
the French revolution erected a statue
to the goddess of Notradame Cathedral,
which I was thought was already telling
historical then that's wrong by the way.
They actually a,
they actually dressed up an opera singer
at to represent the goddess of liberty
and created her around inside the
notradame cathedral,
which they had renamed the temple the
temple of reason.
So I had my remembrance of the
historical factors a little bit off,
but the basic notion is still remains
absolutely solid.
I mean the people who ran the French
revolution were in fact,
at least in the initial stages of the
revolution were out to to replace
Christianity,
Catholicism with,
with rational atheism and to enshrine
reason.
And it was interesting to read some of
the things that they have done because
it's certainly the case,
for example,
that our notion of natural rights
formally derives in large part from the
work that was done by certain people
around the time of the French
revolution.
And what was really interesting about
those authors is that having constructed
their explicit description of natural
rights,
they immediately made the presumption
that they had invented the concepts.
There was no historical basis for the
idea in a sense that there was no
lengthy process of religious development
that led up to the possibility of
positing something like a natural.
Right.
So once having discovered it,
so to speak,
which is to say having made it explicit,
they were willing to dispense entirely
with all of the historical prerequisites
for the development of that idea.
I mean that was the idea here is right.
Say you come up with a rational
explication of the notion of a natural,
right.
Well that's based on on an immensely
long and complex history of the movement
of the sorts of behavior patterns that
are encoded in the idea of national
rights up this hierarchy of abstraction.
So
anyways,
the point is is that as soon as the
French thinkers,
we're able to make the notion of the
national right explicit.
They were willing to dispense with the
historical precursors.
And the reason I'm using that argument
is because I'm trying to make the notion
of evil explicit and I'm,
but I'm not willing to dispense with the
historical precursors.
Cause it's absolutely obvious to me that
the only reason that I can say anything
at all about evil is because all of the
ideas that I'm describing how are
already played out at all these more
implicit levels of analysis.
And what I'm trying to do,
you see,
the thing is about mythological modes of
thinking.
These natural categories is that they do
have really,
really fuzzy boundaries.
And so when you consider this structure,
you know,
every one of these levels of analysis
has a negative and a positive valence.
And it's very easy for us to,
it's very easy for us to make the
presupposition that given that the
devil,
so to speak,
is something negative.
That all of the things that we regard as
negatively vaillant emotionally belong
in the category of the devil.
It's a very easy mistake to make.
So that's,
so it's easy for us to say,
well,
the foreigner like good is,
uh,
adherence to a particular creed.
Therefore,
and foreigners obviously presented a
threat to the integrity of that creed
that threatens negatively valence.
It's reasonable to lump everything
natively valence into the same category.
The category that we lumped,
everything that's active and negatively
valence into is equivalent to the devil,
so you get a perfectly reasonable
logical train that leads to the
demonization of enemies.
Now,
Elaine Paige Mills who just wrote a book
on the on the Devil said that the
actual,
she actually I think reversed the
motivational change.
She said the reason that what
Christianity has come up with what I
think is the most well elaborated story
of the devil and what,
although there are other religions that
have done the same sort of thing and
certainly the notion,
the nature of evil is a preoccupation of
all sorts of moral systems,
but in terms of elaborating up a
dramatic figure,
Christianity has done a very good job of
that page will says the underground
motivation for the construction of such
a figure,
which is the personification of evil,
was to aid Christians in labeling their
enemies as demonic and justifying their
their annihilation.
Now,
I think,
you know,
this is a,
first of all,
it's plausible argument.
Second of all,
it's a potent argument.
Um,
and it,
it also seems fairly obvious that people
do use mythological figures that
represent evil to and apply them to
their enemies to justify their,
you're not alation.
So then you might think,
well,
maybe the whole idea of evil is just a
rationalization that we use to pursue
am's that we want to pursue.
But I would say,
well,
that's not exactly right.
Despite the fact that it's like Freud's
comments about religion.
You can use religion as a,
as a neurotic defense against your
anxiety.
You've death.
Absolutely.
What that means is that you identify
with a given creed in a dogmatic manner
and that protects you from your neurotic
stairs.
Don't want from Freud's mistake as far
as I was concerned,
was to take a perfectly reasonable
observation and turn it into universal
statement.
The statement being,
that's the only possible purpose of
religion.
The fact that you could miss you
something does not necessarily mean that
the misuse of the thing is the only use
of it.
While I'm the same applies to the ideas
of evil.
The fact that having a figure at your
disposal like the devil so to speak,
makes it easier for you in some ways to,
to represent your,
your enemies as reprehensible does not
necessarily mean that.
That's the only reason that such a
figure developed and when I'm trying to
do in this manuscript and this lecture
today is to clarify,
is to bring some clarity to these fuzzy,
mythological categories so that we can
draw a clear distinction between,
well what I would say our idols of evil,
which are necessarily false and the
process of evil itself,
which I think is actually clearly
identifiable and stable across cultures.
Just like all these other things that
we've discussed.
Okay.
Anyone?
Yes?
How could you talk about evil?
Well,
Oh,
you,
you can talk about it by all sorts of
other names I guess like in humanity
might be one or uh,
well,
we,
we do it in psychology all the time.
We talk about antisocial behavior where
we talked about psychopathy,
psychopathy being the thing that's most
closely related in the clinical
literature to classical notions of evil.
But,
and then we say like standard theories
of antisocial behavior.
For example,
and I know I know this literature
relatively well,
they're usually motive.
They're based on,
uh,
on inference is drawn from analysis of
lower level of motivations.
Like you might say that the typical
antisocial person is someone who's very
high in sensitivity to incentive reward
and very low in sensitivity to threat.
That's a standard theory for anti social
motivation.
So that means that they're all goal,
all curiosity,
all novelty seeking and very little
stock.
You can't make the managers so they
don't have inhibitory control over the
behavior.
But,
but that,
that's a pretty mechanistic notion of,
of,
of what underlies criminal behavior in a
lot of research has been being devoted
towards that.
And you know,
the idea of being the standard
antisocial personality,
someone who just doesn't feel anxiety
very clearly,
who can't use cues of punishment to
regulate their own behavior.
Now
there the problem,
I don't think there's any wrong with
that line of theorizing.
I think there are probably underlying
motivation reasons that might propel
someone who's neurotically inclined,
so to speak,
towards criminality rather than towards
agoraphobic or eating disorders or all
the other things that can complicate up
your life.
But what that's missing is any
appreciation for the fact that a lot of
the activities that we regard as
criminal deeply criminal have this
aspect of almost an aesthetic aspect in
a sense,
which is obvious desire to wreak havoc
and harm on someone else,
not merely for whatever gain might be
caused by that,
but very often despite the fact that no
gain whatsoever will be cost by just for
participating in the act itself.
Now,
there's some exceptions to this,
like Dan always who studies bullying in
Scandinavian countries the most
particularly,
he's always been interested in.
One of the things that motivated his
lifetime's work on,
on bullying is understanding of the
authoritarian personality because he's,
he makes the presupposition that bullies
in their henchmen or the juvenile
versions of fascists,
fascists,
and their louts,
which is a perfectly reasonable
hypothesis as far as I'm concerned.
He's documented instances.
For example,
he has a video tape,
which I haven't seen him.
I just read this description of it that
shows,
you know,
it's being taken in a public school in
Norway showing a group of bullies,
tormenting a whipping boy basically by
tying a string around his neck and
leading them through the hallways.
And the thing about that sort of thing
is that it's fun and it's that aspect
of,
of the attractiveness of engaging in
that sort of behavior that we really
haven't been able to get our finger on
very clearly in psychology.
And I think as a rule we tend to,
we tend to sidestep it.
And it's also because we don't like to
deal with issues like equal,
so to speak,
that have these sorts of religious
overtones.
But when you're talking about the sorts
of things that happened in concentration
camps in the Soviet Union in Germany,
which are the sorts of things I'm really
interested in,
you have to use the strongest work you
have at your disposal to describe those
patterns of activity.
And it's also the case that,
well,
as I mentioned last week,
I think a lot of the prior order
surviving Nazis were prosecuted after
the Second World War for crimes against
humanity,
which is,
uh,
which is a category of moral violation,
which we recognize at a sort of super
cultural level,
which is that we say,
well,
yes,
morality is culture bound,
which is to say that different cultures
have different rules.
If you follow those rules,
you're,
you're responsible within the confines
of those cultures.
But despite that relativistic morality,
there are certain activities that you
can't engage in no matter what your
excuses and basically what that,
that's,
that's the thesis of the Nuremberg
trials basically in that thesis is
predicated on implicit recognition at
least that there's a form of morality
that supersedes cultural identification
and also one that a form of morality and
a form of immorality that transcends
cultural identification.
And if you don't believe that,
then it's difficult to justify any
belief that you might have.
That what happened in Germany,
for example,
did constitute a crime against humanity.
Then you have to regard the Nuremberg
trials as an act of revenge by the
victors,
which is an arguable position
question.
I'm just wondering,
I'm trying to understand the context of
mental health.
Um,
I'm wondering,
um,
first of all,
like mental health itself can be defined
like the idea of mental health and need
find this like survival or cooperation
in society or whether it's like,
you know,
we can itself like can have disturbed
person achieves to a high level of
success.
I just,
Hitler did and still be considered.
Well that's,
that's the,
that's the question.
I mean,
I said one of the questions that I've
been trying to answer all along here,
this neat,
she's in Peru,
which is,
are there pathologies of health,
can you be the exemplar of a given
society,
which means by the definition of that
society normally average,
but in fact and still be considered
corrupt at a higher level of analysis
whose existence can actually be
justified in some manner.
And that is the issue.
And that's what we're trying to,
that's what we're trying to find out.
Okay.
So I read you the little story that
[inaudible] told about the elimination
of anomalous information in the form of
other people,
which is not social instance argument.
The social and political unity of the
Communist Party says,
how was it a tank you just eliminate,
you eliminate all anomalous information
that's actually still embodied in,
right,
so an idea log doesn't like contrary
rational arguments because they present
information that violates the of the
logs,
precept positions,
but it's also the case that the mere
existence of certain types of people,
regardless of whether they're making
their arguments in any abstract form,
those people indicate by their behavior,
their objection to our existence in
spite of your particular precept.
So they're mere fact.
The mere fact of their existence is
individuals and sufficient threat to
justify their,
their repression and annihilation.
I would say,
well totalitarians are doing to people
exactly what abstract authoritarians due
to ideas that don't agree with them.
If you present me with information that
doesn't fit my frame of reference,
I'll just
eliminated
you.
Eliade talks about the notion of the
flood and this University of
disseminated myth that says
states of being are annihilated by the
gods periodically,
not only because they are decrepit
as a constant,
just as a consequence of their manner of
being,
but also because people add unnecessary
decrepitude to them by their,
by their sins,
so to speak.
That's a mythological idea and we don't
know what it means.
Now,
I'm going to read you a little section
that describes the authoritarianism of
an individual who I think came to
realize that many of his so called moral
precepts,
the things that he held as as
ideological ideals were in fact leading
him down in extraordinarily totalitarian
path.
MMM,
today is Christmas Day and I have just
come home from Julie's while I was
there.
It struck me as I sat on the couch
between two girls,
just how foolish and idiotic I have been
in this smile and we life.
I hope you want to have patients while I
own burden myself on you because I need
desperately to confess my sins to
someone.
And I know that if I were sitting in a
little cubicle talking to an unseen
clergymen,
I wouldn't do a proper job of it.
You fit the definition of a religious
man as someone who gives careful
consideration to the demonic and
irrational and humanity.
So I think you will find my confession.
Interesting.
Imagine if you can a grown man who
harbors in his heart the most vicious
resentment for his fellow man,
his neighbor who is actually
guilty of nothing,
more than embodying a superior
consciousness of what it means to be a
man.
When I think of all the black scathing
thoughts I have directed at those who I
could not look in the eye,
it is almost unbearable.
All of my lofty disdain for the common
man who so I thought it was guilty of
the sin of,
of unconsciousness was I now realize
founded on nothing more than jealousy in
spite I hated unload anyone who had
wrestled with their fear of leaving the
maternal confines of a childish
mentality and won their battle only
because I had not done so.
I equated independence and success with
ego,
tism and selfishness,
and it was my fondest hope,
my highest ambition to witness and
participate in the destruction of
everything that's successful,
independent people had built for
themselves.
This,
I consider it a duty fact.
There was a decidedly fanatical element
in my urge to cleanse the world of what
I perceived to be selfishness.
Okay.
I think of what would have happened if I
had been in a position to realize my
fine feelings.
The memory makes me fear that any moment
the earth,
we'll crack open and swallow me up
because if there was any justice,
it would I who have not the faintest
inkling of a capacity for moral judgment
traipsing around passing judgment on
anyone who Derek Cross my path.
It makes me wonder that I have even one
friend in this world,
but of course I had friends before,
anyone with enough self contempt that
they could forgive me.
Mine.
It is fortunate for humanity that there
are a few saviors of the caliber of
myself.
If you know that I use to identify with
Christ,
I considered myself entirely
immaculately free of aggression in every
other form of antisocial feeling,
but what about the hatred I have just
now confessed you ask.
That didn't count.
Those feelings were based on sound
common sense,
uc.
After all,
there are sons of bitches in the world
and one needs to be ready for them.
Do I smell ozone?
They say you get a tingling sensation
just before the lightning bolt strikes.
That is a very apt phrase,
son of a bitch.
There's a passage in young's
phenomenology of the self which runs
often.
A mother appears beside him who
apparently shows not the slightest
concern that her little son should
become a man,
but who was tireless in self emulating
effort,
neglect,
nothing that might hinder him from
growing up in marrying you.
Now,
behold the secret conspiracy between
mother and son and how each helps the
other to be trade life.
This insight would be useful for me as
an excuse being a perfectly accurate
description of my situation.
We're not for the fact that I'm almost
daily presented with a residual bit of
undeleted evil and myself.
For example,
when I am faced with a frustrating
situation,
I do not ask myself what I am going to
do about it.
I asked myself who's responsible for it
and I'm always ready to conclude that if
the other person were to ag property,
then the problem will not exist.
What is evil,
the boat that you ask?
Well,
obviously if I am determined to overlook
my own part in the failure to resolve my
own frustrations,
I,
if I'm determined to find a scapegoat
for my problems,
then I'm just a stone's throw away from
the mentality that was responsible for
Hitler's final solution or for the
Spanish inquisition or for Lennon's
cultural cleansing.
Okay.
What was it you told me when I
complained about the flaws in capitalism
about the fact that so many people take
advantage of the capitalist system,
something like the fact that people go
on consolidating their financial
position ad nauseum is another problem,
but it is no reason to conclude that
there anything virtuous in even refusing
to try to cut consolidates one's
position in the first place,
but it is much easier to crown ones,
cowardice and laziness with the accolade
of virtue.
Just ask Lens Henchman.
He swaggered around the countryside,
robbing every farmer who had managed any
success whatsoever and called themselves
friends of the common people and patted
each other on the back for their moral
uprightness.
I wonder if I've actually changed so
much that I would not join them if I was
put to the test.
The idea that morality stems from a lack
of personal interest is thoroughly
ingrained in my mind.
Good people are those who don't want
anything for themselves is the way I
think,
but I never asked myself why is such a
person shouldn't put any effort into
disciplining himself or take any pains
to keep his motives clear in his own
mind because there's nothing of value to
him in this world,
in his essay relations between the ego
and the unconscious,
he don't says that in an unconscious
state,
the individual's torn by the conflict of
opposites and that achieving
consciousness involves resolving that
conflict on a higher level.
Right.
I understand that this particular
statement,
Cha a Dalton consciousness is different
from the original state of childlike and
consciousness in which there is no long
term conflict.
Just last week I was stuck in that dead
end again.
I was sitting and thinking about what
course my life should be taking and had
every imagined scenario of a fulfilling
or meaningful activity.
I was met by a counterpoint coming from
somewhere in my head showing me how this
or that aspect of my scenario was wrong
because it wouldn't result in this or
that problem.
Yeah.
To the point where it was unacceptable.
Consider any career at all because just
by being alive,
I would contribute to the destruction of
the planet
and as badly as I want it to refute this
echo of wrong to my every emotion,
right as an irrational Kymera.
The fact is,
so I told myself that we see daily in
the newspapers how the activities of
humanity,
which are also the activities of men and
women are causing and Calkin will farm.
It is of course,
due to my being influenced by yourself
that I do not remain stuck in that
particular blog too long these days.
If our industrialism was causing
problems,
I know Lawrence for myself than I should
hope that there are people out there
working to solve those problems,
or perhaps I should try to do something
about them myself,
but sitting idly by,
I do know what it's all the thing.
Of course,
what is most daunting and also most
sniffily about being stuck in that Bhag
is the fact that the rational wide wants
to be absolutely sure about the
successful outcome of its life plan.
I know,
obviously there's another part of the
mind that knows that such certainties,
impossible when has been faced with the
need to accept on faith that things will
turn out for the better and with some
luck and perseverance.
Okay,
and being a fine,
upstanding modern mouse with an
enlightened rational mind.
I have no use for faith and other such
religious Santa clap trap and nonsense
or faith is obviously your rational and
all not have any here rationality
influencing my behavior previously.
My solution to this problem was to allow
a chance to make my career choices for
me,
letting my own interests influenced my
decisions as little as possible.
And then I believe that I had somehow
avoided personal responsibility for the
state of the modern world because I was
not really responsible for the state of
my life and that eight escape from the
possibility that my plans wouldn't work
out because I had no plans.
It was on this rock solid foundation
that I looked out at the world and saw
all around me,
people who were stupid enough to add
their own selves into the equation,
put this kind of faith in oneself to
believe that there exists inside of one
a motive force,
call it an interest which will respond
to life and carry one through
uncertainty and adversity is an
irrational attitude without equal,
and it is with this irrational approach
to life that the conflict of opposites
is resolved,
it seems to me,
but the problem now is this.
In order to have this faith in one's
irrational nature,
one needs proof that personal interests
and passions are capable of sustaining
one through the uncertainties and
adversities of life with the rational
mind foresee so clearly,
and the only way to get that proof is to
risk one self and just see the result.
Okay.
It is a very exceptional person you can
take such under taking on their own.
Most of us need guidance and support
from others,
from believers,
so to speak.
Strange,
isn't it?
That religious terms should become
useful for this discussion.
As I wrote that last paragraph,
I was suddenly reminded of your idea
that the devil has,
he has represented Milton's paradise
lost is a metaphor for the rational
intellect just being placed in the
position of the highest psychic
authority.
Okay.
Better to rule and how then to serve in
heaven.
Hell,
Dan is a condition in which the rational
mind with its acute consciousness of the
many perils of life hold sway over the
individual and the fact of Lee prevents
him from engaging in life,
which results in the morally degenerate
state of weakness that I described in
the first pages of his letter.
Okay?
And Heaven,
I presume,
would be a condition in which the
rational mind subordinates itself to
faith in God.
What is God?
You have a chapter in the manuscript of
your book towel titled The Divinity
Interest.
Your ideas are starting to make sense to
me now at least I think they are.
Faith in God means faith in that which
Kendall's one's interest and leads one
away from the parental sphere out into
the world.
To deny those interests is to deny God
fall from having it land squarely in
hell where one's passions burn eternally
and frustration was it God said when he
cast out amount of Eden,
so I'm thinking about working in the
dust at the end of his days with the
specter of death always looming in the
future.
I can certainly relate to that.
One of the most vivid impressions I get
from recalling all those years I spent
moving from one job to the next is the
pointlessness of my daily life back then
and the glaring knowledge that the end
was drawing near,
but when I'm doing something that has
meaning for me,
something that interests me as I am
right now,
death seems far away and work seems
quite agreeable,
even joy us.
Well,
there's two things or more about that.
I guess the first is that the writer of
this letter points out that the only
thing that stopped him from,
from being Hitler or Stalin for that
matter,
or perhaps on where you want to,
Hitler or stale intention was lack of
opportunity.
It's not lack of will and that it's easy
for us to make the presupposition that
there's a qualitative difference between
someone like Hitler and it's our Ed of
men or stolen and someone like
ourselves.
Partly because we're never in the
position to do any of the sorts of
things that those bands did and as a
consequence it's,
we can use our difference in position to
support our notion that there's a
qualitative difference,
but he points out,
I think this is interesting also in
terms of more current news about the
unabomber because the unabomber was a
person who had this sort of attitude
that's described in this letter,
which is that he made the presupposition
that industrial society,
him excluded was evil and the
appropriate thing to do was to
disassociate oneself entirely from all
contact with that society and having
done so presume and begin to fix it from
an outside all on his own.
And I know in terms of psychological
profiles,
I mean I know what the unabomber is like
is on the outside.
He would appear as someone who was
absolutely could we essence who would do
anything you told him to do.
They would never cause any trouble
whatsoever.
Who would appear as someone who was
actually composed almost entirely of low
self esteem and doubt,
but who deep inside believed that he was
far superior to anyone that he'd ever
encountered on the earth.
That's how I mean it's from a position
like that that you can then move rapidly
towards justification of doing things
like blowing up in innocent people who
theoretically partake in what you
consider inappropriate from a distance
having severed for moral reasons.
All possible contact with with a real
members of humanity supported in his
endeavors theoretically from pity and
care by both his mother and his brother
who sent him money to sustain is
completely abnormal,
exist as long beyond the point that it
would have been sustainable on its own.
I also wanted to read you another
section from social [inaudible] and on
the authoritarianism of the individual.
This is the ideological,
logical version.
So we have the first story that
describes the consequences of a
totalitarian ideology,
put it to action,
which is the necessary pursuit and
destruction of people who don't share
the ideological view.
And then we have the mythological notion
that things go from bad to worse on
their own,
but people tend to help that process
along.
But as a consequence now and man,
God decides to obliterate the world.
And then we have an individual story in
which one person who confesses that
given his presuppositions about the
state of the world,
had he been in any position of authority
whatsoever,
he would've been a very terrible person.
And in fact that he was a very terrible
person,
but he was also powerless.
So he didn't look terrible because he
couldn't put any of his fantasies into
action.
And this is,
I do thing,
this is what separates most of us from
the position that someone like Hitler
found himself.
Because I do actually believe that that
Hitler was not
a particularly pathological individual.
MMM.
He had a decent first world war record,
his sort of aimless wandering throughout
Europe.
At the close of world war one or that
much different from the aimless
wandering of any number of hundreds of
thousands of men who'd be unbelievably
brutalized in trench warfare during
World War One.
MMM.
See,
the thing is,
it's not to say that a man in that
position was without faults because he
certainly had as many faults as the next
person did.
But the problem is is that no,
if you,
if you put yourself into a position of
power,
what you forego is the sort of social
feedback that keeps most people in line.
So you can say,
well,
you know,
if the average individual is composed of
a certain amount,
positive qualities and a certain amount
of negative qualities,
but being relatively powerless,
the average person has always kept in
mind by the social pressure of his or
her peers.
So for any of us,
theoretically,
if we start to move too far in our
naturally pathological direction,
we receive instant.
We receive instant feedback from our
surrounding environment suggesting that
it might be better if we want a fire
behavior,
which is to say that people have enough
courage to be irritated by us and let us
know that,
or people have enough courage or aren't
sufficiently terrified of us,
which is the same thing in a sense to
tell us when we've gone too far out of
wine by gesture and look and interaction
and all sorts of things.
So you know,
we all,
that's part of the security that the
social group provides.
You know,
a social group makes everyone else
predictable,
but it also keeps us predictable to
ourself to by ensuring that we told the
line the problem with accruing power in
the manner of someone like Hitler is
that you forego all that social
corrective feedback.
And then because you surround yourself
by people and it's a process that feeds
back onto itself,
you surround yourself by people who are
essentially cowardly,
who want to hide behind your charisma,
so to speak,
so that they don't have to face the
world and they're willing because you
protect them from the things they don't
want to look at to exceed to your every
wish.
Now in some ways that can be perfectly
positive.
I read a good biography of Hitler,
I thought that claimed that had he quit
or being killed or died in the mid
thirties that the judgment of the German
people and perhaps of history overall
would he'd be in the pain of being a
very effective leader.
You know,
you might debate,
perhaps it's debatable.
I haven't read every biography of Hitler
that's out there,
but the problem was that as things
continue to,
as his power continued to grow,
his pathology had a wider and wider,
wider,
wider latitude for expression.
And then,
you know,
the question really becomes,
so you can say,
because it's comforting that there's a
qualitative difference between someone
like Hitler and the person who's sitting
next to you.
But then you also have to think when the
whole country of people think that
you're the answer to all their problems,
what sort of character and what it take
to,
to tell yourself that all those people
are wrong given especially in say
inhibitors case.
The exceptional odds against him have
ever him having ever gone to the
position that he got to.
He was a pretty,
he was trivial person from a,
from a socioeconomic and military
perspective.
He didn't come from a powerful family.
He had no influential friends to speak
of.
And he climbed up the ranks of the
hierarchy unit,
remarkable manner and you know,
gain the gain,
the democratic acceptance of the vast
majority of the German population.
And he also viewed himself as someone
who was,
Germany's only hope,
partly as a bolt.
Like he viewed himself as a bulwark from
the encroachment of communism from the
East,
which was a real threat.
And also someone who could conceivably
restored Germany to some of the power
that had been stripped from,
from the country by diverse side
trading,
which I think is reading.
It's reasonable to comment on that
training that it was blatantly vengeful.
So you'll have to ask yourself,
well,
under those conditions,
given,
given that much admiration carried out
over such a lengthy period of time,
how many people wouldn't fall prey to
their own pathologies?
That's one of the things.
Blending very interesting.
Sort of enjoyed as much personal powers
anymore.
You have to seem to have a discipline to
survive.
Right?
Right.
Some degree.
I mean it makes it because the hip or
pattern is much more common.
Right.
Then the wake on these,
I'm just curious when you think about
that.
Well,
I mean it's,
I don't know exactly what to think about
it.
I mean,
perhaps here it's just surprisingly
lacking anthropologist.
Well that's one possibility.
I mean he was also,
he was also explicitly religious.
He had engaged in also,
I've always thought personal incentives.
Yeah.
I think that,
I think that was part of it.
I mean he was willing voluntarily to
four gold,
many of the,
the rewards that he might've otherwise,
I guess basically what he did was to,
to try to discipline himself so that he
as a matter of habit would reject any
temptation that was offered to him.
I mean,
he did some strange things,
you know,
like,
or things that seem strange,
I think like I remember that Gandhi used
to sleep with young women in order to,
to attempt to suppress his sexual desire
grow.
Right,
exactly.
And you think,
well that's kind of a strange thing to
do.
And then you think,
well,
you know,
this guy,
here's someone who is like absolutely
surrounded by temptations of every sort,
you know,
in any direction that he would have
chosen to pursue whatever he wanted,
he would have been granted it.
And perhaps the only way he could keep
himself vaguely on course was to forego
all of the,
all the temporal attractions of his
power as powerful position.
I also think again,
the perhaps had prepared himself for the
sorts of things that he might encounter,
um,
beforehand.
And he engaged in a lengthy letter
writing correspondence with tolstoy
before he started his,
his nonviolent movement in India.
I also suspect that maybe as his power
grew,
his character grew too because he was
making the right decisions all the way
along.
So you know,
when,
when he was offered a small temptation
so to speak,
perhaps he was able to say no.
And then the next time when the
temptation,
the slight be bigger,
he,
you know,
it got easier.
That's right.
It was something that was practice.
Maybe it's a good question.
We may be confusing situations here.
I think you can apply the same analysis
that you used for Hitler in terms of
Gandhi.
His,
the reason why he was powerful is
because you enable to resist these
temptations.
So as you accumulated power and
accumulated power as a saint,
not as a political leader in a sense,
is there a lot of political leaders in
Indian?
So you're suggesting too that there was
social pressure on him to keep him on
the positive?
In the positive direction as well.
I said,
yeah,
well I think that's right.
I mean,
if everyone expects you to act like a
saint as well then and you're going to
have to have a moral,
right?
Absolutely.
Well,
yeah,
I mean certainly these sorts of feedback
processes exist.
I mean,
that's why I said there's this statement
in the new testament run something like
to those who have everything more shall
be given to those who have nothing.
Everything will be taken away.
What do I think that is?
His description of this sort of feedback
process is that one good decision
heightens the likelihood of the next
good decision and so on and so forth.
So invent,
as you make your decisions,
events conspire,
so to speak,
to reinforce them.
You can see this with paranoids like
Stella.
I mean,
if you're paranoid,
you think everyone's out to get you well
as,
which means that you're very hostile and
suspicious towards people,
which means that you see their dark
side.
It also makes them very afraid and
suspicious of you so you can see you
very [inaudible].
So,
you know,
that sort of thing could spiral out of
control very,
very rapidly.
I dealt with that.
Well,
just one of the really intriguing things
about God
as well as the same,
which is sort of an unusual combination.
And there are many who,
uh,
as far as his sainthood,
we turn out not to be,
I mean witness Ben tollerene evangelists
and all that specific claim to authority
is being holier than the rest of us who
then ultimately turn out to be that.
So there's still something very
extraordinary about this personal
discipline or whatever it was
what,
yeah,
you had sex with young women,
you're not calling that?
No,
no.
He just slept beside that.
Beside that.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yes.
Um,
and then to heighten his ability to
resist,
that was his theory.
I mean,
who knows.
Um,
what do you think of the difference
between like,
the sort of second process of denying
the temptation versus like sort of
denying other people's idea of like in
both the same sort of,
similar in like you're saying,
um,
I'm acknowledging some part of me and
they,
I mean,
they're both thing.
Um,
not acknowledging some,
pardon me,
like
no,
there's a difference between refusing to
acknowledge something and technology,
but picking a particular course of
action,
like I may say say we're in involved in
a heated discussion and you make me
angry.
I mean the appropriate response on my
part is to recognize the fact that I am
in,
that I am angry and north to pretend
that I'm knowing because good people
don't get angry.
But then once having recognized the
fact,
choose that pattern of behavior that I
feel is appropriate under those
circumstances,
which might be to say,
you know,
we'd better stop having this discussion
because I am in fact getting angry or,
or you might say something like,
um,
for reasons I don't understand entirely
what you're saying is really irritating
me.
I don't know necessarily where the ducks
up an appropriate reaction or not,
but it's really the one that I have.
That's the sort of thing it was actually
put to some therapeutic can
you just fight people like Carl Rogers
cause he used to do that sort of thing.
So it's not a matter of like,
it's not the pretense that the
uncomfortable fact doesn't exist.
It's choosing to deal with it in some
conscious man,
which means planned manner once it's
actually manifest.
One other thing that you mentioned
before we hit like most of the leaders
seem to charismatic because they seem
like they were unified in that like
different president personality all sort
of fit together well.
Sure.
I would say now that you've been about
someone like Hitler.
Yeah.
I mean if somebody's
in that way to differently,
depending on whether you follow all your
temptations and death,
like all your names of set as satisfied
or
he just said when nature discuss
morality,
he said that most morality was
cowardice,
which basically meant that it wasn't
that people were good,
it was just that they were far too
afraid to act on those motivations but
actually propelled them.
But at the motivations were there and
that given the opportunity with no with
no chance of
Oh
punishment,
people would act them out.
And you see this sort of behavior in
riots,
for instance,
where the likelihood of being caught for
committing a criminal act decreases to
basically zero and you know,
anti anti social behavior,
so to speak,
spreads through the population like a
play.
Oh,
I think the reason that people like
hibbler are attractive from a
charismatic perspective.
And this also goes from gangster
figures,
for example,
in American movies.
So there's an absolute plethora is that
people do tend to admire.
Okay.
People do tend to admire those
individuals who may see as courageous
enough so to speak,
to act on their darker impulses.
And I think the positive and the
negative reason for that is pure desire
to imitate.
But the positive aspect of that is that
we know what some mythological level,
so to speak,
that
the movement from conventional cowardice
driven morality to a higher order
morality involves necessarily taking
into account a whole plethora of
motivational states that are normally
regarded as unacceptable,
like regression and the potential for
cruelty.
And,
uh,
I'm,
I'm inhibited sexual desire and so on
and so forth.
And
anyways,
that's part of the reason why I think
we're attracted to people like gangster
fingers.
Do you think it's also because we're
witnessing someone with an effective
strategy for accomplishing their goals?
I mean regardless of what the content of
that strategy is,
that's an overall construction.
It is.
Well they get,
sure you could do that.
And I would say that that's,
I would say that's more the negative end
of the aberration.
I mean the point is,
is that,
did you ever see the movie goodfellas?
Yeah,
I hated that movie anyways cause I
actually thought it glorified the mom's
terms under the guise of
showing how despicable they weren't.
But that's okay.
It's a debatable,
debatable proposition.
Certainly the goodfellas believe
themselves to be certainly superior
beings because they got what everyone
else wanted without letting fear stop
them.
And there's a certain element of truth
to that because one of the things that
does is stop many people from getting
what they want.
It's fear.
Now you can conclude from that,
that you should remove all fear and then
do whatever it takes to get exactly what
you want.
But you can conclude from that.
That fear is not necessarily sufficient
justification for not trying to pursue
the things that
you want.
So coded interview data,
one of these firms,
it is them.
One of the questions that people had
responded to was to name someone they
admired and why,
and this was seven years ago in a
disproportionate number of people said
that they admired Ross Perot.
Amazing they admired him is because
essentially he seemed immune to social
influence seem to uh,
people said things like,
I admire someone who stands up for what
he believes in
whether or not other people agree with
them.
Someone who that doesn't change his
mind.
Okay.
Even when he's wrong,
even when he might be wrong,
someone who sticks with somebody about
these gangsters seems to resonate with
that sense that they seem immune to,
well sure there's a certain,
there's a certain aspect of
individualism to that,
to that whole,
like in the gangster Motif,
it's criminal individualism,
but it's still indicative of the
capacity to stand up,
up against group morality.
And the thing is,
there is an aspect to heroic behavior,
so to speak,
that requires the incorporation of the
sorts of aggressive and defiant
attitudes that,
that in and of themselves characterize
gangster behavior.
Now though I would say that
from the perspective of archetipal
individual behavior on the positive
side,
incorporation of those aggressive
aspects is necessary.
But Darwin nation by the MS is counter
productive.
But that still doesn't mean,
you know,
if you're a little boy and you'd get
beat up on the playground,
you might say,
well it's better to respond nonviolent.
But really that's a mask for the fact
that you had to swallow the defeat and
couldn't respond violently if you wanted
to.
Now the appropriate response to that
might be to develop the capacity to
respond violently and effectively,
but not to use it,
which is,
which is to say the absence of the
capacity to respond harshly is no
evidence for morality,
which is,
uh,
which is
a point you tried to make over and over
and over again.
So if you can't be cruel,
not being cruel is not moral,
it's just,
it's just your rationalization for an
inability.
And I think that argument's very
powerful.
So I know,
I also think that's part of the reason
why we're so drawn towards people who
act out their darkest fantasies because
they're doing something we would like
to,
but won't.
That doesn't mean the thinker thinks
should stop there.
But say that Jesus' parable,
parable of the gnostic gospels that
you're talking about,
the person acts,
right?
Right.
That's exactly what it's referring to
hold.
There's this story that Christ is
walking down the road on the sabbath and
he sees a farmer in the ditch and he
farmer sheep is falling into a hole and
he's pulling the sheep out.
Christ says to him,
if you know what you're doing,
do,
you were blessed,
but if you don't,
you're transgressor of the law in your
curves.
Anyone just walking down the street is
the same idea.
[inaudible].
So the guy who was pulling out the
sheep,
if he's conscious,
has come to terms with his capacity to
violate social rules and this,
using that to pass being then to pursue
a higher order level of morality.
That's one way of interpreting the other
way of interpreting it,
that he's just careless and acting and
callous self interest in it.
So it's the thing that's interesting
about that as the same act.
It's just intense differ.
How's that?
Yeah.
You're not supposed to.
No supposed to work on the Sabbath.
Oh,
sorry.
Right,
right.
That's the,
that's the,
that's the law.
The moral law.
Right.
Flip it over and say,
if you were completely ignorant of the
law,
then he wasn't coming and we're cleaning
meditative act against the law.
Well,
the,
the notion of being ignorant about the
already doesn't enter into that
particular parable.
To me,
if you're completely ignorant of the law
and you break a rule,
then you're in the situation of a child.
And really just like children bring
social norms all the time.
People don't make any presumptions about
their evil.
And as a Jennifer rule,
because they don't know the rule.
So the assumption that he knew it was
the sabbath,
right?
That's the assumption.
The assumption is he knew it was the
sound.
Exactly.
That he wasn't just acting like,
I'm like remarkable ignorance.
Okay.
So let's,
I'm gonna read another story and this is
from soldier Knutsen and this has to do
with the ideological version of
authoritarianism.
So Solzhenitsyn is lying with his friend
Hannon railway car that's being set up
to transport prisoners from one
concentration camp to another or to a
concentration camp to begin with.
There's my friend Patton and I are lying
on the middle shelf of a stolen and
department and setting yourselves up
comfortably.
Tarp salt hearing in our pockets so that
we don't need water and can go to sleep.
But at some station or other,
they shoved into our compartment of
Marxist scholar.
We can tell this from his goatee and
spectacles.
He doesn't hide the fact.
He's a former professor of the communist
academy.
We hang head down in the square cutout
and from his very first words,
we see that he is impenetrable.
But we have been serving time for a very
long time and we have a long time left
to serve and we melt value.
Uh,
Mary joke,
we must climb down to have a bit of fun.
There's ample space left in the
compartment and so we exchange places
with someone in crowd in.
Hello?
You're not too crowded.
No,
it's all right.
Have you been in the jug a long time?
Long enough?
Are you past the halfway mark?
Just look over there.
How poverty's tricking our villages,
our straw thatch,
crooked hats.
It's an inheritance from the czarist
regime.
Well,
but we've already had 30 Soviet years.
That's an insignificant period.
Historically,
it's terrible that the collective
farmers are starving,
but have you looked in all their ovens?
Just ask any collective farmer NARC
compartment.
Well,
everyone in jail is embittered in
prejudiced,
but I've seen collective farms myself.
That means they were uncharacteristic.
The goatee had never been in any of them
that way.
It was simpler.
Just ask the old folks under the czar,
they were well fed,
well closed,
and they used to have many holidays.
I'm not even going to ask.
It's a subjective trade of human memory
to praise everything.
In the past,
the cow,
the died is the one that gave twice the
milk.
Sometimes even cited proverbs and our
people don't like holidays.
They'd like to work.
Why is there a shortage of brand in many
cities when right before the war,
for example,
not true before the war,
in fact,
everything had been worked out,
falling into precisely at the same trap
he just described.
Listen,
at that time in all the cities on the
vogue of the recuse of thousands of
people,
well that was a local failure and
supply,
more likely your memory's failing you,
but there's a shortage now,
old wives tales,
we have from seven to 8 billion bushels
of grain.
The grain is rotten,
not so we have been successful in
developing new varieties of grain and so
forth.
He's imperturbable.
He speaks in the language which requires
no effort of the mind and arguing with
him is like walking through a desert,
which is the emergence of some
mythological imagery.
By the way,
it's about people like that that they
say he made the rounds of all the
blacksmiths and came home on shot and
when they write in their obituaries
perished tragically during the period of
the stellar count.
It should be corrected to read perished
karmically.
But if his faith had worked out
differently,
we would have never learned what a dry,
insignificant little man he was who
would respectfully read his name in the
newspaper.
He would've become people's commissar or
even venture to represent all Russia
abroad.
To argue with him was useless.
It was much more interesting to play
with him.
Not a chess but at the game of comrades.
There really is such a game.
It's a very simple game.
His play up,
Tim a couple of times or so,
use some of his pet words and phrases
here like it for his.
He has grown accustomed to find that all
around them are enemies.
He's become weary of snarling and
doesn't like to tell his stories because
all of them will be twisted around and
thrown right back in his face.
But if he takes you for one of his own,
he will quite humanly disclosed to you
what he is seen at the station.
People are passing by,
laughs,
laughing,
talking life goes on parties providing
leadership.
People are being moved from job to job,
that's for sure.
Yet you and are languishing here in
prison.
There are only a handful of us and we
must write and write petitions,
begging a review of our cases,
begging for a pardon or else he will
tell you something interesting.
In the Communist Academy,
they decided to devour one comrade.
They decided he wasn't quite genuine,
not one of our own,
but somehow they couldn't manage it.
There were no errors in his essays and
his biography was clean.
Then all of a sudden going through the
archives,
what a fine.
They ran across an old low brochure
written by this comrade in which
Vladimir Ilyich Lenin himself had held
in his hands and in the margin of which
he had written in his own handwriting.
The notation as an economist,
he is shit.
Well now you understand.
Our companion smelled confidentially,
but after that it was no trouble at all
to make short work of that model had an
imposter.
He was expelled from the academy and
deprived of his scholarly rank.
The railroad cars go clicking along.
Everyone has already asleep.
Some line down,
some sitting up.
Sometimes a convoy guard passes along
the corridor yawning and one more
unrecorded episode from Lennon's
biography is lost from view.
I read,
I read you that story because it is,
it provides an interesting relationship
between the adoption of a totalitarian
position and the necessary consequence
of that adoption,
which is instantly the desire to torment
and persecute anyone who doesn't belong
to that particular tall attarian
position.
I would say,
well,
it's not just a matter of,
um,
the desire to protect the integrity of
the totalitarian position.
That's part of it.
It's also the fact that adoption of the
totalitarian position allows those who
have adopted it to rationalize and
justify their admitted desires to take
revenge on the world.
And I would say,
well,
why do they want to take revenge on the
world and the revenge on the world in
the form of other people?
Why would you want to take revenge on
the world?
It's because from your perspective,
the world has tortured you unjustly and
unfairly.
And under those circumstances,
the only logical thing to do is to,
in fact attempt to extract your revenge.
Or we know already from looking at the
myth of genesis and the kind of the
story of the fall of the Buddha,
that there's ample reason in the average
human life.
You don't have to have a pathological
background to have had enough
experiences to make it appear to you
with,
with a substantial amount of
justification that the fundamental
conditions of life are sufficiently
unfair.
So that the logical thing to do well
being alive is to work for the
destruction of life.
When we're,
I said that we were going to spend a
fair amount of time trying to build up
some representation of the personality
that is being used in mythology to
represent the evil.
And it's kind of complicated because it
isn't some,
it isn't something that you can just
list asset as a set of fixed attributes.
You have to get an idea of the dynamic
nature of the process.
And,
uh,
while I'm trying to do that by telling
you some different stories that
hopefully fit into a pattern,
but I also want to outline some of the
things that seem
what you said earlier in the lecture is
that,
um,
and you said this last section that
human,
that humans see more danger in the
unknown that they,
because of their cognition,
but what it seems to me,
what you just said right now is that
their cognition isn't necessarily made
the end on a more potent,
but that it attributes no tomorrow kinds
of things and the danger to more kinds
of things.
And so this,
this guy or people in that veteran a to
talk to [inaudible] um,
uh,
regime,
whatever it can see the unknown and more
kinds of things,
the abstract it to other things rather
than necessarily things be more potent
or I would say that it's also the case
does it,
you can see it we're animals wouldn't
see merely by party because you can
switch frames of reference and something
that's known and one in one frame of
reference is unknown in another.
And you can also imagine there's ways
where things that seem comfortable at
the moment might indicate some potential
danger in the future,
which is what you do when you worry.
And when you worry,
basically you're somewhere safe.
I mean,
as a general rule,
it's not always the case.
I mean,
if you're somewhere unsafe,
then you're afraid of that and that's
what we're worried you usually you're in
a,
you know,
in your living room chair,
whatever.
And you were attributing emergence's of
the unknown to all sorts of
potentialities and perhaps trying to
problem solve at the same time.
What is,
what is unfair and unjust?
Well,
I would say a unpredictable,
that would be one aspect of it because
you can't learn to avoid something
that's unpredictable.
And also,
um,
like I think we tend to regard a
punishment as just if it's only
sufficient to eradicate the behavior
that preceded it.
So for example,
I mean we just,
we strive towards that in the criminal
justice system,
right?
That's what it means.
That the punishment should fit the
crime.
Well,
first of all,
I think is that there should be a crime.
And often we seem to be punished.
And despite the fact that there's no
evidence of crime,
and it also should be that the,
the punishment is the right match for
the crime.
And that's,
it's hard to understand what that might
mean.
But if you look at how you treat,
we'll say a dog or that you're trying to
train him to not do something,
if it pees on your rug for example,
there might be a punishment that you
would consider sufficiently matched to
that act so that it might be regarded by
the dog is just so,
um,
like a swat on the behind with the
newspaper rather than,
you know,
being beat half to death with a stick,
for example.
So the source of the sense of
appropriateness.
Well,
wow,
that's a good question.
I don't,
I don't exactly know how that's worked
out.
I think a lot of it's trial and error.
I can't really say much more about data
at the moment.
I mean it's partly looked like if say
you're dealing,
I see this with my children.
The question is how do you,
how do you,
cause you,
you,
you have to use,
I think you have to use a
negative feedback as well as positive
feedback to set borders around children.
And then the question is,
well where does the notion of what
constitute just punishment come from and
not sort of interaction?
Well,
you have to experiment with people in a
sense to determine the nature of their
temperament.
Because for some people,
for my daughter,
for example,
if I point my finger at her and say no,
she's doing something that she shouldn't
do,
she'll stop.
Whereas if I do that with my son,
well that's just irrelevant.
I mean that that level of punishment is
completely negligible.
So for him,
what constitutes a just punishment?
As far as I can tell,
it's something that's like higher up in
intensity than it is for my daughter.
And that's probably a matter of
temperament.
So,
well that's possible.
He's also younger than her,
you know,
but yeah,
that
is more sensitive to punishment and they
sell in the younger one.
Yeah,
we have like my family here,
I would be the oldest and I was like
people being mad at me.
That was an,
yeah.
Yeah.
Next Sibling,
Dallas Wild One.
You know here,
here's another example.
In English common law,
you have the,
you have the right to use reasonable
force to protect yourself against
violation of your rights by an intruder,
which basically means that if someone
breaks into your house and you have a 45
revolver,
you can't shoot them without saying
stop.
I mean it's a little more complex than
that,
but the point is is that you have to,
you have to use the minimum amount of
force that's necessary to stop the thing
that shouldn't be happening.
And I think that's a,
like that's a critical aspect of justice
along with the notion of predictability.
I think those are the two.
Those are the two poles of justice as
far as I'm concerned.
Okay.
So anyways,
what we're trying to do is to figure out
what his personality is characterized
by.
It's complex because there's a feedback
problem though.
I would say like why is it,
see if I can get the argument down.
Pat Say
the personality of evil is characterized
by a tendency to deny error,
so a totalitarian personality is someone
who can admit to being wrong and I would
say,
well that's equivalent to not being able
to deny the existence of this
information.
Because when you say I wasn't wrong,
what you're saying is that the
information that I've received,
which indicates that there's a flaw in
my argument actually doesn't exist.
There is no such flop,
but she,
he might reinterpret the information or
you might readjust your fear,
totality gelateria and idea to some
degree to shut the ideo or effectively
or whatever.
But it's,
I guess what I'm saying is that refusal
to admit to error is exactly the same
thing as a denial of anomalous
information and I think that's why where
why one of the hallmark attributes of
the devil in classical mythology is
pride because that's what pride is.
Pride is the statement on it's more than
that.
It's normally the state that I never
make a mistake,
which is the,
for me,
there's no anomalous information.
That's also the statement for me.
There is no anomalous information,
isn't the statement for me.
There's no one that's Florida territory
and the statement that for me,
there's no unexplored territory.
It's exactly equivalent to the
presumption of personal omniscience.
It's the same thing.
If there's no unknown,
I know everything.
Well,
Milton story,
that's,
that's the,
that's the story of Satan's fall as the
description,
mythological description of a pattern of
behavior just characterized by implicit
adoption,
loss,
explicit,
and that story explicit.
A dog should have a missed him.
So we're saying,
well,
what does that mean?
Well,
it,
it instantly involves these other
things.
Pride,
arrogance,
totalitarianism.
Now you might say that
follower of a creed rather than the
origin nater of a creed isn't someone
who's presuming personal omniscience.
What I would say,
well,
they're even more corrupt than the
actual leader because they say,
well,
he's the boss.
He's gone.
I'll do everything he tells me.
So they're actually,
they're actually eliminating there.
At least the person who establishes the
dog dogma,
like Hitler for example,
is taking a personal part in the
construction of the theory.
Someone who follows Hitler has
completely abrogated any personal
responsibility for making any moral
judgements whatsoever to the leader.
So I think actually the followers are
more pathological than the leader.
But that's,
that's,
I think that's true.
So these are,
these things all make a complex,
which is one of these natural categories
as far as I can tell.
And the question,
well,
what are they lead to?
Well,
I would say that the reason that there's
a negative here and a negative here is
because these two processes feedback
onto one another,
which is to say,
remember,
all you have said that we had a set,
it wasn't on a lonely age that made
systems decrepit.
It was the sins of men.
So then the question is,
well,
what does it mean?
It was the sense of men.
You have to ask,
what does sin mean?
Basically from the mythological
perspective.
And that gets you into a discussion of
the question of evil.
And I would say,
well the thing that underlies evil most
fundamentally is the process of the
denial of anomalous information,
which is to say that you have a theory
kind,
a piece of evidence pops up,
which according to your own criteria for
truth,
because you set that as well,
indicates that your theory is actually
wrong.
It's not.
It doesn't have to be objective back of
any sort.
It's by your own criteria.
Some things popped up that indicates
that you're wrong and you say,
well no,
that thing doesn't exist and you can say
that lots of ways.
You can just
see Freud thought you had to actively
repress information,
anomalous or traumatic information,
but that's not right.
You don't have to actively repress it
because it's a sin of omission and not a
sin of commission.
Because if a piece of novel information
comes up and you do nothing about it,
then you haven't processed it.
Right.
It's to,
to take into account a piece of global
information means that you have to
explore the thing that's normal,
draw the necessary behavioral
conclusions and update your scheme of
representation.
So it isn't as if when something novel
pops up and you admit to its existence
automatically the way you think is made
proper,
it's that to actually process something
normal,
you have to go through a tremendous
amount of work.
Some of the work which actually involved
one of these sense and resurrection,
so to speak,
that we talked about.
So if you're
okay,
finish the argument here in a sec.
Uh,
so we have,
we have a sin as to the Nile of anomaly,
but we have original sin already is
curiosity,
which is precisely the opposite.
Hmm.
Okay.
Let me see if
it's more than of curiosity.
It's the
desire to be on a status.
It's also dial.
I guess
we expressed it as curiosity here last
week.
Yeah.
You also mentioned last week if there
was it.
There was a paradoxical aspect to that
because the gnostics for example
regarding the serpent tempted,
Adam and Eve has a higher order day than
the god that had created things to begin
with.
And that was a heretical position from
the perspective of the sec that
developed into the standard Christian
Church.
But it's also the case that even in
Catholicism in the mini and medieval
era,
original sin was regarded as a fortunate
sin because it was a precondition the
for the drama of the passion.
So you could say,
well
original sin was regarded as a precursor
of evil because it was curiosity that
knocked Adam and eve out of paradise.
And also the took the boot outside of
the walled city that his father had set
up.
So from that perspective it's very
negative,
which is to say that it's curiosity and
that brings a nominalist information to
into an otherwise stable system.
But from another perspective,
which is broader,
I think you might regard it as a
fortunate proclivity.
So I think it depends on your,
on your temporal frame of reference.
And I don't think,
I think that's a kind of a standard.
I think that's a reasonable
interpretation.
It's something we'll return to actually
in the last lecture of this course
because there's a myth that young pulled
out from England that actually addresses
that point directly.
It's just a paragraph long,
but it describes,
well it tries to put original sin into
the context of the whole,
the whole story of redemption,
which isn't just Christian,
it's just the story,
you know,
a stable preexistence state
deterioration into a state of chaos and
then a regeneration on a more integrated
playing original sin.
Original sin is a portrait and
necessarily a problem.
Sure.
I mean if you look at it from the
perspective of being in chaos,
so we say you're in chaos.
You say,
well,
what got me here?
Well,
if I were to just shut up and not
bothered going down that path,
that my curiosity drove me down,
then I'd still be,
you know,
sitting comfortably ensconced at home.
I wouldn't be in this horrible stew of
emotional wretchedness that I'm in,
which is,
and I think you know,
if you think about that story read
large,
the notion is,
you know,
if we wouldn't have developed this
cortical cap that allows us the ability
to manipulate abstract bits of
information had never become self
conscious at all.
We would have been in a,
in a paradise light position like the
animals who are in a sense beyond good
and evil.
Now,
Voltaire said,
well not,
I included Voltaire's little commentary
on that line of logic and he said,
well,
what's the,
I know more succinctly putting this,
I don't remember who said this,
it's better to be an unhappy philosopher
than a happy paying that sort of nest.
You can also think of that as a form of
pride anyways.
Of course the ultimate attainment is to
be an unhappy pain
anyways.
Okay.
Have you not considered modifying your
vocabulary since the meeting of your
vocabulary in this climate is it takes
on the meaning of that which would have
been taught the representative of the
church where it's where the devil will
be used to.
Describe the stranger and evil will be
used to describe things that go against
the car and moral code?
Well,
I don't have,
I not considered one to five my
terminology because because of that
likelihood,
I mean
are you not concerned?
It causes so
much confusion to use,
to use the,
to use a word that has been used both as
the,
uh,
denial of anomalous information and also
the generation of new information
depending on the perspective of the
person who sets you apart,
like are taking a very sophisticated use
of the word devil.
Yes.
Well,
hopefully
your readers haven't,
don't have,
you're a sophisticated use of the word
devil.
The devil is the devil because in your
shoulder and mercy from God whispers bad
things in the area,
which is what you know,
and it tells you,
it tells you that you should break away
from the long curved.
Right.
But that's all.
But that's also the case,
like for example,
in this parallel,
but you brought up again,
I mean depending on the,
okay,
so there's a guy in the ditch,
he's taking a sheep out of the whole,
well,
the reason that he's doing it determines
the morality of the action,
not the fact of the action.
So the problem is is that it is the case
upon occasion that the thing that tempts
you away from group identification is
not the positive exploratory spirit.
Like,
okay.
I would say there are two consequences.
There are two political consequences to
the refusal to admit to anomalous
information.
And one is the construction of a
totalitarian state,
either as something that defines your
personality or as something that defines
your whole culture,
depending on how pervasive that
particular pattern of action is.
And that's the one I'm kind of most
interested in because it's being
totalitarian and fascist states that,
at least in the 20th century appeared
and I've done the most damage.
But there's also another form of
political disintegration that that might
be more clearly classified as decadence
and decadence,
is the refusal to adhere to a,
to a traditional morality to begin with,
justified by arguments such as well
that's all archaic and useless
information to anyhow and free spirits
such as myself,
which means I'm disciplined and useless
creatures in their totality or actually
the kind of heroes who are going to
transform the world.
So I would say that for people who are
following the roof to decadence,
so to speak,
when the devil talks,
he says,
uh,
cultural rules are all tyrannical and
nonsense.
So the problem is,
is it the,
the interpretation of the process is
entirely context dependent and you
can't,
you can't make it simple for that fact
because the same act in two different
consequences can have two completely
different moral advances.
Nisha said at one point,
you know,
if you're,
if you're out in the front of your
group,
the first thing you should make sure of
is that you're not running away.
Like you're thinking,
Hey,
I'm going out here in front.
I am leading.
But the truth of the matter is you might
no be meeting at all.
You might just be running away as fast
as you can and using the idea of your
leadership to justify the fact that you
just can't cut it.
And like a lot of what passes for
counter cultural creativity and
revolutionary thinking is not at all
that heroic Willem wave from the
confines of group identification,
but pure lack of disciplined,
a pure lack of discipline masquerading
as heroin.
And it's just as dangerous as fascist I
think.
And it's also a precursor to fascism
because if you get a society that
sufficiently disordered,
what that will produce is a tremendous
desire for the establishment of a rigid,
rigid structure.
So
anyways,
is that,
does that,
uh,
well I think that was just saying
perhaps the devil bagels is writing
about,
it's not the same.
Definitely the cheer writing.
Well you the,
yeah,
I think that's true,
but the,
the only way I can think of it is the
same in a way.
The question,
and I think it is,
or the issue is to develop a
sufficiently delineated notion of what
constitutes evil.
So that we can see the difference
between the things that are just
normally classified into that domain in
the things that should be classified
into the dome.
So,
so symbol,
it operates on many levels
to make sure you're talking about which
level you're referring to it on theirs.
It's hard to say.
We also,
you could have been referred to it since
the whole,
since what you're doing is this is the
whole mythology of the devil.
Well,
you know,
saw you run into a problem like this,
we know familiar and is portable.
Them see you're reading your demo is
from paradise lost,
which is a different depth.
I never read paradise.
I grew up with the devil,
which isn't the same devil once your
done reading very different.
Right,
right.
You're a devil is like,
um,
is like the Godfather,
you know?
But well,
I would say,
I would say it is the,
it is the case that what Milton do did
was attempt to codify what he saw as the
fundamental traditions of the devil and
Christian and True Christian mythology
that had be,
and it'd be gathered up to that point.
It's like,
here's an example.
Look,
we know familiarity,
that it's a natural tendency,
so to speak,
to assimilate the forerunner to the
dragon of chaos,
right?
Is that it's not even an assimilation.
It's a natural tendency of people to be
unable to distinguish the 400 from the
dragon of chaos.
Well,
we know that dragon imagery plays a
large part in our mythology of evil.
So it's very,
it's very easy for us to contaminate up
our notion of,
you know,
the serpentine aspect of evil with the
foreigner.
What I'm trying to do is to say,
well,
look there,
there are some things that we tend
naturally to regard as evil because
they're negatively valence,
that that are only tangentially in
situationally associated with evil.
But there is one thing at the core which
is a process that that is actually right
at the basis of the evil.
Oh and I'm,
I'm trying to build up a map of what
that,
of what that her a personality
characterized by that process with me.
Sorry.
I said,
well the first thing is,
is that the totalitarian personality
rejects any notion of the possibility of
personal layer.
Now people sometimes hide from
themselves when they're doing by saying,
well,
it isn't that I'm personally omnicell
and it's that I'm an adherence say of
Communist ideology and it's Communist
ideology.
That's absolutely right.
And I just happened to believe it.
But I think that's just rationalization
is you get all of the advantages of
being on this yet without any of the,
without any of the disadvantages.
So it's really,
it's really,
really powerful.
So you can see how arrogance is relating
to that without any problem.
But there's also the notion of this act
is there's an underlying notion there of
the sacrifice of the hero,
which is also implicit in the whole
notion of the rejection of the anomalous
information.
Cause we said already that the positive
aspect of the individual is the aspect
that voluntarily admits to the presence
of anomalous information and then
modifies worldview,
either his coworkers or the whole
society as a consequence of that contact
with no.
So there's recognition of the
uncomfortable fact,
then exploration of the fact then
generation of an adaptive structure to
deal with the fact and then
communication of that adaptive structure
out into this social community.
And that's the hero of pattern.
Well if you don't do that,
if you do the opposite,
then that's tantamount to rejecting that
whole process.
So I would say that someone who refuses
to admit to the possibility of personal
error also sacrifices their identity
with the heroic aspect of the
individual.
That's also a necessary consequence.
And then you say,
well what are the consequences of that?
Well,
the consequences,
they're simple.
First of all,
there's only two ways of protecting
yourself against the unknown.
One is by directing group
identification.
And the other is by identifying with the
process that makes sense of the unknown.
And most people do both.
And that's perfectly reasonable costs,
right?
We had doctor,
our group identifications,
and then we try to make sense of those
things that are anomalous that happened
to us personally.
So that's a nice balance.
So you can either identify with the
hero,
so to speak,
or you can identify with the group.
If you forsake your identification with
the hero voluntarily,
which is to say that you say there is no
such thing as anomalous information,
then the only thing that you've got left
to protect yourself with his
identification with the group,
and that makes the likelihood that
you'll identify rigidly with the group
much,
much higher because you don't have an
alternative anymore.
So like if you know that you can cope,
then if someone comes along,
well,
let's take a look at this in terms of
personal relationships.
Like let's say you,
because I have a personal relationship,
can adopt to totalitarian,
uh,
can adopt the totalitarian mode with no
problem.
Let's say you're extremely dependent on
the person that you're associating with
and,
uh,
someone threatened stuff person.
Well,
you're going to get extraordinarily
upset about this because you've
sacrificed your own ability to deal with
that known through your dependency.
So you're much more likely to need the
person that you're with than would
otherwise be the case.
In fact,
you're going to be so dependent on them
that you're going to use all sorts of
vicious underground tricks to ensure
that they don't abandon you.
But anyways,
the point is is that if you eliminate
this as a possibility,
basically the,
the theory runs like this,
you draw the conclusion that the
negative aspect of the unknown is so
terrible that there's no possible way it
can be dealt with.
Which is to say you're making the
presupposition that life is too terrible
to bear.
As a consequence,
you eliminate your identification with
the positive aspect of that,
of the individual.
That makes you much more likely to adopt
tie,
ironical identification with the
patriarchal structure.
Cause you've,
you don't have a process that you can
actually engage in contacting.
Yeah,
I know.
So
it's also the case that is,
Yep.
Is the opposite of work.
What goes to the negatives there was if
you rejected them,
occasional group and only would be your
role.
The opposite of,
oh well I would say,
hmm.
No,
I would say [inaudible] is a consequence
of viewing the tyrannical ass of viewing
society is only tyrannical and seeing
that as even more of a danger than the
negative aspect of the unknown because
it has a positive aspect too.
So I say in both cases,
decadence or fascism,
there's,
it's still characterized by,
by the elimination of identification
with the hero.
The hero is the opposite.
True possible,
which is elimination of identification
with a group.
Oh yes.
I see.
On that level.
That would be decadence.
Yeah.
Then that would be bad.
If it's motivated,
if it's actually motivated by the
inability to put up with any discipline
because the problem with like group
identification has a cost.
I mean you have to follow the rules and
that's hard.
Now for some people,
the threat of following the rules is
more to be feared than the threat of the
unknown.
Especially given like if you're a
decadent,
so to speak,
you get to revel in all the positive
aspects of chaos as well.
So you get to,
you know,
maybe you have an ex exceptionally
promiscuous lifestyle and you use all
the mood altering drugs you can get your
hands on and,
and you live for the pleasurable moment.
So I mean there's lots of positive
aspects to chaos,
right?
And that are hidden from you by the
necessity of identifying with the group.
So it doesn't,
the thing that deck the decadence takes
place in a,
in a highly developed societies so that
you can sort of take for granted all the
politics society has given you.
And that's why you're getting the
positive out of the unknown because
you're just sort of thing you're denying
it.
You have to follow the rules,
but at the same time,
wrestling on all the time.
Absolutely.
It's a short,
of course that's exactly the cakes is
that you're protected by the thing you
despise despite the fact that you
despise it.
It's so powerful that it can bear you
along while you're doing everything you
can to undermine it.
Sure.
That happens all the time.
You know,
Nisha said at one point,
I mean this is the kind of statement
that can be easily interpreted as
fascist and you know,
need,
she gets interpreted that way now.
And then he said the strength of a
society can be measured by the number of
parasites that it can bear.
But he,
what he hit the point he was making was
that the point you're making.
So although,
you know,
you can see how taking out the context
that that statement perhaps
well can be viewed as support for an
exceptionally powerful right wing
position.
Okay.
So,
but you know,
I'm not getting at it yet exactly what I
want to get at.
So we have a personality.
It's characterized by all these
necessary consequences.
There's no anomaly that's equivalent to
saying,
I know everything,
uh,
identity identification with the group
is also equivalent to rejection of the
heroic.
But the other thing is,
is that right?
That's the motive that I really want to
get at.
The idea I guess is that the development
of self consciousness,
which means knowledge of mortality,
um,
heightens the negative valence of the
unknown to such a degree where it's easy
to draw the logical conclusion that life
is such an unfair process than it should
be brought to an end.
And I wanted to read you a quote from,
from Girtha mean characterizes
Mephistopheles,
uh,
Mephistopheles central thesis.
So mephistopheles means Prince of lies
and alive.
So that's another attribute of the
classical devil.
And of course the lie is that anomalous
information that upsets your particular
system of belief doesn't exist.
That's what characterizes and lie.
Anyways,
Mephistopheles has an express credo and
it goes something like this.
The spirit I that endlessly denies and
rightly too,
for all that comes to birth is fit for
overthrow as nothing worth wherefore the
world.
We're better sterilized.
That's all that's here is evil
recognized his gain to me and downfall
runes sin,
the very element type prosper in.
And guess that repeats that philosophy
in part two of files.
T says this is memphis softly speaking
again,
gone to share,
nothing passed with no made one.
What manages our creative,
endless toil.
When Adis snatch oblivion ends the coil.
That's the question that's posed in
genesis.
It is by gone.
How shall this riddle run?
As good as if things never had begun yet
circleback existence to possess.
I'd rather have eternal emptiness.
So mephistopheles credo is basically
that the evidence implies that the
conditions of existence are sufficiently
unfair in and of themselves,
such that it would be better if nothing
existed at all.
And I would say that's that conclusion
is,
well,
first of all,
it to conclusion that people draw from
time to time on the basis of the
evidence that exists.
But I would also say that if you abandon
your identification with the process
that makes order out of chaos,
that's the conclusion that you
necessarily have to draw as a
consequence of the nature of your
experience.
Because if you eliminate from your life
all those things that are positive,
which occur as a consequence of your
voluntary tendency to move out into the
world,
all that you'll be left with necessarily
is constantly evidence of the existence
of unwarranted pain and suffering.
And under those conditions,
the only logical conclusion to draw is
that any state of existence that is
characterized by constant in one
unwarranted pain and suffering obviously
deserves to be youth and angst
eradicated.
And I think that's the motive that
underlies the acts of genocide that
accompany totalitarian thinking.
But here's an example.
There's recent biography of Stellan
published.
I've only read a review of it.
Two books actually I want to pick up
that have been written very recently.
They are very relevant to this course
and that's one of them based on archive
material.
Well,
the biographer reveals that still in
this sort of person that we've been
describing.
I mean he was an extraordinary and cruel
person,
rigid totalitarian,
paranoid.
Well,
what was his plan?
This biography thinks there's a good
possibility that he was murdered,
which is a good thing by all
appearances.
Um,
it looks like what stolen was doing pr
prior to his demise was,
well,
he like his,
his acts of evil had escalated in
magnitude over the course of the years
that he was in power.
And as he got more and more powerful,
that domain of visibility to put his
evil fantasies into action increased
this burger for claims that Stellan near
in the years that led up to his death
was in facts planning to start a nuclear
war with the West.
And that all of the systematic acts of
genocide that he had committed in the
Soviet Union might be regarded as trial
runs,
which I would think of as practice.
You know,
the first person is hard to kill,
but once you kill one person,
one of the second person isn't so hard
to kill him.
And once you get to,
well it's not so hard to wipe out 20 and
maybe once you're pretty good at that,
a thousand doesn't bother you anymore
and then you can practice on a few
million.
And if that really doesn't distress you
too much,
well then there's always the possibility
of blowing up the whole world.
And that's what motivated Stella.
And I think,
and I would also say that those of us
who,
who tend to think of people like Stellan
and Hitler as entirely foreign entities
haven't come to term with the sock
terms,
with the fact that there's a big chunk
of our personality whose credo is
precisely that have Mephistopheles,
which is that the world and its
conditions are so unfair in reality that
the best thing we could possibly happen
would be for all this to come to an end
as rapidly as possible.
And I would say that under normal
conditions,
we work out of this part of our
personality and this part of our
personality too.
And generally it's a tossup which part
gets the upper hand.
So to the degree that this part gets the
upper hand,
which is pretty constant,
the likelihood of a tear radical state
increases in in magnitude.
And you might say,
well,
you know,
that's a ridiculous argument because the
actions of one individual don't have any
relationship to the consequences at the
level of any political maneuvering.
But I would say we don't have the
foggiest clue what causes things like
the Holocaust.
We don't know why the Cold War started.
We certainly have no idea why it ended.
And as far as I'm concerned,
it's premature to conclude on the basis
of hard evidence,
ignorance and our inability to stop
things like the Holocaust from occurring
that we have no idea how the actions of
the individual might be related to the
development of genocide states.
So I'm suggesting that they might be
alive much more closely than people have
been inclined to believe.
And I'm also suggesting that part of the
reason that people have been inclined to
believe that they're not very closely
aligned is well because well,
partly because of the individual
responsibility,
the magnitude that individual
responsibility that seems to imply
processes all the flies.
Absolutely.
I mean I think you can even make a
physiological argument to buttress that
point,
which is that
to the degree that you're engaged in a
constant in the constant voluntary
processing of anomalous information,
your life is interesting and meaningful
by definition.
In fact,
the circuitry that you activate when
you're engaged in voluntary exploration,
which is a consequence of admission of
anomaly is in fact what we call meaning.
And to the degree that you're engaged in
a meaningful activity,
you can put up with all the nasty
preconditions of existence that make
that sort of exploration possible.
Which nature said if you have a,
uh,
why you can bear any how and basically
what he meant by that visit.
Despite the fact that life perhaps
necessarily has terrible preconditions
for it to exist at all,
it might be rendered bearable and even
positive if you would only participate
in those things that you know to be
correct.
Well,
it's a reasonable hypothesis.
It's also what everyone,
if
you could discover what it is that
everyone would want,
if they could really figure out what
they wanted,
that would be it.
Because the story says if you pursue
those things that you personally find
most meaningful without deceiving
yourself as to their content,
what will happen is that you'll develop
a mode of being that enables you to look
on life as if it was a beneficial
process.
And that is what people want when they
say something like,
well,
what is like given this terrible thing
that's just happened to me?
What could possibly be the meaning of my
existence.
Say Well,
okay,
I have your,
I have almost all of your papers aren't.
It was two of them that aren't mark and
I'll have them ready on Friday.